now there is no single chart I can show
you or even selection of charts that's
going to tell you the full story The
Definitive story what's going on in the
health system right now but we can make
a start and we get a kind of sneak
preview of looking what's going on and
one of the most striking things is
looking at Staffing levels versus
performance levels or versus output
because what you can see and this might
seem surprising is that actually there
have been a considerably more staff in
the NHS now than there were back in 2019
so pre-pandemic particularly in those
front line uh areas so nurses
Consultants support staff to clinical
staff senior managers as well and Junior
doctors all of those level Staffing
levels are up considerably but does that
transfer through to actual procedures
well no we're going to bring on
procedures look at the bars
those procedures have gone down okay so
GP appointments first cancer
appointments up but outpatient
appointments people coming off the
waiting list elective admissions
emergency admissions all those red bars
they are down so it's this strange
Paradox where you've got Staffing up and
then procedures down and that's one of
the strange things that people are
trying to to work out to understand at
the moment as there are other kind of
metrics of performance so many of those
metrics are similarly depressing this
one just shows you how many people are
having to wait uh for two weeks or
indeed more than two weeks for a
consultant a first consultation for
cancer the higher this line is the more
people are not having to wait uh over a
fortnight so the higher this is the
better things are and what you can
probably make out is that line was
actually above where you might hope for
it to be up until around kind of when is
that 2017 2018 but then even before the
pandemic it was starting to come down a
little bit then you had covid and look
at this line
so you're going for about five percent
of people facing uh those long Waits uh
to about 25 of people it's a real sign
of you know those concerns uh with the
UK health system which of course leading
to worse outcomes for patients
particularly uh when it comes to cancer
and there are many charts we could look
at that show you a similar story in
different parts of the health system
one other kind of potential explanation
for this you know it's not necessarily
Staffing because we have more staff in
hospitals but maybe it might be
something else it might be a shortage of
hospital beds places to treat people and
typically
this is the kind of range at which we
would expect to see long occupancy in
hospital beds over the past few years so
that's the typical level here's this
year we're in at the moment look 2022-23
actually significantly higher than
normal so more people stuck in hospital
beds for longer and what are the
explanations for that partly it's
because it's tougher to get discharged
because you've got problems in Social
care right now so you don't necessarily
have the beds and the care to get to but
partly it's another story which is we
don't necessarily have enough of those
hospital beds and when you look at the
big picture here comparing the UK to
other countries around the world well it
really is Stark the UK has one of the
lowest levels of hospital beds per
thousand of the population of pretty
much any country within the oecd so the
developed world and I should say these
charts have looked like this for quite
some time the UK had kind of low
investment and low hospitals for a long
time and the story when you come to look
at things like MRI scanners or CT
scanners is even worse like the UK the
very worst in the developed world when
it comes to CT scanners so that's very
striking but if we take a step back and
look at overall investment well here's a
chart you might have seen something like
recently this is showing you capital
investment in health so basically how
much the government is investing of
putting into the health system and that
kind of gray area is many other
countries around Europe you can see them
there so from Austria and Canada as well
so it's got Canada and the US as well
and France uh too that's where they are
but the red line is the UK and you can
see up until about 2010 the UK was
tracking along more or less mid-table
and then you had austerity then you had
the big cuts in capital spending and the
UK becomes an outlier and that's well
it's pretty Stark isn't it but here's
the thing if you take a different range
of countries an ad for instance Spain or
Japan both of which have health systems
which some people have said are kind of
similar to the kind of Beverage style
health system that we have in the UK
look We'll add them on and then suddenly
that pack is a bit bigger and the UK
doesn't look like an outlier anymore
actually other countries are low lower
and the UK just goes from being kind of
Hymer table to being quite kind of low
mid table not saying that's necessarily
a good thing but it does just underlying
it's a really complex story right now
the thing you can't dispute is the fact
that you have some serious problems the
NHS is facing pressure right now and no
one is entirely sure whether there is a
quick fix for it